I always felt Buster Keaton had a rubber  face and was great and almost everything  he did silent he happened to be in mad  world I need a chance to work with how  to give him anything every second of the  mad world  I'd have to say Harold Maude I would  think so you know I've been called crazy  and so but I enjoy my crazy no sir  it's how crazy you go and now before you  go with it because they will put you  away and then you can't be crazy at all  so you have to be have to know where  you're playing and who you're playing  with  I think I'd be an artist which I'm an  artist anyway I started out to be an  artist and looks like I'll probably end  up being an artist  working on borrowing a use cellphone I  failed in the first grade so the  technology is always been acquired  you